hello everyone so we will be
starting in a few more minutes and let
everybody else join us
thank you for joining us today
welcome to our research fellowship
presentation meeting
if you are joining us for the first time
today i am deepshaviswas the
bioinformatics community manager
at pine biotech the research project
program
has been designed to help young
researchers
and students take advantage of the
bioinformatics resources
for analysis of complex high throughput
life science data
and become versed in bioinformatics
this program offers you to participate
in real
and cutting edge bioinformatics research
and be part of a renowned bioinformatics
the research fellowship is a program for
independent research
projects where we learn about the
application of bioinformatics to big
high throughput or mix data
mastering the tbio info cloud based
bioinformatics platform
understanding of ngs data expertise with
biostatistical tools
and machine learning concepts effective
use of functional
annotation and biological interpretation
cutting-edge research with supervised
and unsupervised multi-omics
integration apply tools to interpret
meaningful insights and start your own
bioinformatics
ngs project and these
are the different research areas that we
focus on
like oncology biology neuroscience
microbiome and agriculture data science
and machine learning
i would like to invite dr mohit mazumdar
our omics logic
project guide alpine biotech to talk
more about the bioinformatics research
dr mazumdar over to you thank you uh
biphobia
okay hello everyone so let me share my
screen
uh yeah so today i wanted to talk to you
all about uh the
uh research fellowship program and what
we are actually doing in this program in
the term
in in in the sense of projects and
the research that we are conducting with
our fellows here
who have joined this meeting as well so
to give
to give you a background over the past
20 years
there has been a phenomenal growth in
the adoptation of high throughput
technologies
like next generation sequencing in
research
biotechnology and clinical practice so
these technologies
produced exponential uh growth
of publicly available omics data right
so this trend produce has produced many
exciting challenges that could be solved
that could be solved
by extracting this sort of information
and knowledge from this data
so for example to learn about the nature
of
malignant processes and the relationship
between clinical between clinical
phenotypes
and their molecule and their molecular
drivers
that's an example so this process of
posting relevant data
for pressing research needs has also
been
uh accelerating including a major
increase in public sharing of omics data
during this ongoing pandemic
so importantly this sharing of data is
just not about the
biological phenomenon but in-depth view
of
actually you know what's going on so at
a molecular level if you want to
understand
this data which we are talking about and
analyzing
every day is called or referred as the
omics data
so today i wanted to also give you an
example in the context of
uh maybe precision oncology or precision
medicine
so precision medicine aims to empower
clinicians
especially to predict the most
appropriate course of
action for you know patients
with complex diseases such as cancer
diabetes
cardiomyopathy kovi 19 so
so with a pro with this progressive you
know interpretation
of clinical data and then uh
molecular data and then genomic factors
that are at play in many of these
diseases
so accumulation of all this data
and more effective and personalized
medical treatments could be anticipated
right for
many disorders because we are not just
talking about
one kind of information we are
collecting different kind of omics
information
along with the clinical information
along with uh
epidemiological information and then uh
we we are trying to predict a right path
a right path for uh a patient care
so this understanding of uh you know
different types of omics
uh including like patients metabolomics
and their genetic makeup
in conjugations in conjugation with
clinical data will definitely and
significantly lead to
you know determining uh predepositions
diagnostics prognostics and
predictive biomarkers and this path
which we are taking in for precision
medicine
is ultimately going to provide optimal
and personalized care
for this diverse and you know targeted
chronic and acute uh diseases and this
uh diverse
population for for a diverse population
right
so most of this data that you that is
generated
uh are generated randomly
because it uses a high throughput system
and
it is generated at a very high speed
right
and then to do analysis of this data
it requires a complex computational data
processing
so that is one of the challenges
that anyone any biologist or anyone
interested
in learning these sort of omics data has
to
overcome so uh this
process or the process of a procedure to
generate a structured data set
uh a structured data set where we have
labels
where we understand the um
the where we have removed the artificial
artifact artifacts and understand the
biological
uh uh connection of data
that have been generated for a
particular particular experiment
right so sorry
so it is important now to understand
this kind of structured data the next
step
after you have processed this data and
to be able to visualize this
and to be statistically understand what
is the important
importance of this experiment or the
data set that you are analyzing yourself
so in the context of you know current
pandemic
so scientists around the globe are
working to understand this noble
coronavirus
how it spreads how it evolves
uh and also the genetic sequencing has
provided
enormous insights so since saskof2 virus
is a
is an rna virus it naturally
acquires mutation right so this nature
so
this mutations that are happening at a
really uh
fairly consistent rate
uh many of these mutations uh that are
happening within the
uh virus i mean in in the context of
biology
so they do not they they
may not be important in the context of
you know the infection
but those uh particular uh mutations
like different type of mutations that we
are
uh getting information about could be
important for
uh you know understanding that how it
spreads
or how it is affecting or infecting uh
individuals uh globally so drawing those
relationships
out of uh you know different data sets
is some of the things that we do that in
that includes like going through
scientific literature
then uh looking at the sequences looking
and finding those
mutations which are like really uh
connects with the population
data with the with the spread of what we
are seeing
so finding those kind of correlations
and then tracing them back to the
structure
is uh one of the research that we kind
of focus on
for infectious diseases
and you know this next generation
sequencing and today we wanted to talk a
lot about next generation sequencing
data because uh one of the major
objective of this sort of training is to
go through
and understand this uh hugely available
uh publicly available data sets so this
is a really powerful tool for tracking
those mutations as i said
genomics and even monitoring for
patients
infection progression and immune
responses such as these
so one of the key benefits of ngs is to
ability
its is its ability to scale
so for instance uh sequencing system
can simultaneously sequence more than
100 000 samples
but again the challenge itself is about
is is to able to understand and analyze
that
huge amount of information and that's
why we call it like
big data
so talking about the um ngs technology
and how it connects
and you know in the context of the
current pandemic and not just in the
context of the current pandemic but in
the in
context of infectious diseases this so
this technology is really helpful
for understanding diseases such as ebola
tuberculosis and
papillomavirus so all those infectious
disease
problems are really
can help these ngs data sets are helping
really
uh us to gain deeper insights into these
uh these diseases and their progression
so
um and this sort of data is really
widely available so millions of sequence
you saw thousands of genomes that are
available
in these repositories and these
repositories contain are from like
ncbi and other uh joint genomic uh
integration databases are there so these
databases are also growing really uh
fast and at an exponential speed
so in the end in the context of
bioinformatics research and
bioinformatics research project
uh so what can be done with this data
so anyone including you here can
find a relevant data set can find a
relevant data set and
learn how to analyze this data data
using different tools and techniques
learning about the research method
uh to analyze and discover new things
and explore new ways
finding and gaining insight from this
data and apply data science techniques
so one of the
major uh you know challenge with this
data that i've been talking about
for quite some time now is that that how
do we find patterns and gain
insight and learn about the you know
about the biomarkers that we talked
about learn about the patterns
that would give us you know class that
could help us classify patient groups
so we use uh several ai or
multiple ai or machine learning
algorithms
such as use of support vector machines
logistic
regression and looking for the factors
and discriminant analysis
we can do to classify two groups then we
draw decision trees
that helps us you know again
classify uh unsupervised
or supervised techniques so random
forest is another method
linear regression native base so these
are different types of
uh you know machine learning uh methods
that are used to find and gain insights
from this sort of data
and in the end we kind of are exploring
the scientific knowledge that we are
extracting
and then we are trying to find decide or
predict
and in the end what we are trying to do
is uh
trying to connect this connect the dots
to complete and
you know find uh find a solution or
complete a story or to complete a
research project
so to talk more about how we do this and
what we do in in a research fellowship
program and how
we kind of go from one step to another
uh
successfully uh finding data and
converting that data into
uh finding information from the data
through these complex methods
with ease i would like to pass it on
pass it back to biepsia to talk more
about the program
thank you thank you so much
uh dr mohit i will be sharing my screen
right now
and while i'm sharing my screen uh you
all
can see a poll this poll is to help us
know more about you so we have
three questions the first question is
we would like to know more about you
please share your research interest with
us
so you can put in any of your research
interest here
and if you find that it is not mentioned
in these
five points you can also mention that in
the chat box
the second question is have you done any
binder matrix internship before
and the third question is have you
worked on any bi-informatics projects
before
so as i continue with the slides please
continue putting in your votes
so talking about the research fellowship
program
it is typically offered for either three
months
or six months if you have already
completed
any online training or have a degree in
bioinformatics or are well versed in
bi-informatics
we then recommend the three-month
research fellowship program
this program will help you develop a
research proposal
and complete the analysis independently
while working with a mentor
and support from like-minded
collaborators
if you are new to buying for matrix
and you want to learn as well as develop
a research proposal or conduct an
independent research project with a
potential poster or publication
then the six month research fellowship
program is for you
in this program you will get training
access to ongoing programs
and the support of a community as you
prepare and complete
the research project
now i would want to introduce you to a
few resources that we have
developed for our research fellows and
our biofuel matrix community
in general
so these include training materials
research articles as well as research
projects that you can learn from
the first resource we recommend everyone
to start with
is the introduction to bioinformatics
course
this course starts with a survey that
helps us learn
more about your interests and then the
course explains to you the different
applications of bioinformatics
in life science research in the past
few weeks we have also been working on
to launch a few blog posts related to
bioinformatics
internship opportunities application of
ngs in malaria research as well as a
guide on finding omix data for
alzheimer's disease and shortly i will
show you how to access all of these
resources
by signing into edu dot t
hyphen bio dot info you can find the
link
to the website or the educational portal
in the chat box edu dot t hyphen bio dot
info our team
has also designed some new projects for
our research fellows to learn from
before they can start working on their
own project like the ebola virus
covid19 liver cancer and tuberculosis
every month our team adds new example
projects taken from
peer-reviewed publications on different
areas of bioinformatics research
so please start by creating a
free account on edu.t bioinfo
and now let us go back to the website to
view some of these projects
so this is the edgeo.t hyphen bio.info
website
once you come to this website you will
notice that there are
a lot of courses then there are projects
that you all can start exploring the
registration
to this website is free and you can
register either via
your email id or by using any of the
social media accounts
and once you are logged in you would
notice under courses there is a course
called
introduction to buying for matrix and
that was a course which i was talking
about earlier
this course will give you an
overview of the different ways the
bioinformatics courses are taught here
it's an asynchronous course which means
that it's a course for
self-study that you can take at your own
pace
and time and to introduce this course
there is a video that you can go through
so i will also be posting the direct
link
to this course right in the chat box
again
so it is necessary if you are intending
to join the program
or if you are just new to this community
to start with the introduction to
bi-informatics course
as it will give you an overview of the
different applications of bi-informatics
we recommend this course for
both beginners as well as for
researchers and faculty who are part of
our bioinformatics community
so you see there's an intro survey and
then there are different lectures which
are divided into separate sections
so as you go through this course you
will also learn about the other
asynchronous courses that you can again
take from here
and see how the module is designed
next coming to the projects that we were
talking about
so you see that here are the
tuberculosis project the covid19 project
liver cancer
and these are not the only projects if
you scroll down you will find different
projects related to oncology
as well even neuroscience so please
take a look through these different
projects
and the third resource which i was
showing you is our blog platform
so this blog is where we create
articles which i just showed you some
images of so for example this is a very
interesting article on the different
bi-informatics opportunities
that are available so please feel free
to explore the blog section
as well and all of this is available
freely to everyone
who is a member of the educational
portal
and i would also want to invite you all
to go ahead
and be part of our social media groups
and communities and the reason you
should be part of a community like ours
is because
you are not only getting um
to know a community of students but you
can see
the researchers as well as faculty
and those who are working at different
bioinformatics companies
cancer research institutes all over the
world who are part of this community
so this is a free resource and this is
open for everyone to go ahead and take
part in
so please go ahead and join our groups
we also have a group
on facebook as well so you can take part
in either of these groups and community
and also share
your ideas and your views with everyone
else
now let's go back to the presentation i
hope that
if you have not already created an
account
you would be creating an account right
now and we would be getting started
so now i would like to explain the
research fellowship
process with you and the goal as we know
is to come up with our
own independent project so how
does this step-by-step process work
so this entire process starts with the
very basics the
introductory courses that i have shown
you
so these courses are based on not just
introduction to binder matrix but also
other comments topics
like transcriptomics which will
introduce you to ngs or rna-seq data
analysis
metagenomics epigenetics and more
so this will build up your idea about
what omics logic is so you learn the
logic from these basic courses
then you go ahead and get familiar with
the projects
why is it helpful the projects will help
you to learn
and to see how others have
approached a biological problem and
solve that problem so their approach
will help you
get a better idea of how you should
approach a similar kind of a biological
problem
right and while you're doing step one
and two we recommend you to keep a
journal
and how is the journal helpful you
should note down
each and everything you are doing in
that journal so we recommend all of our
research fellows to either
have a google document or a presentation
like i am showing here
where they can record each of the steps
they are doing which means it starts
with
giving a review of the courses they are
doing
it shows that how you are understanding
each of the courses
and our mentor team can guide you
similarly
in case you are not understanding
something and you would also
understand the different uh problems or
the challenges that you're facing when
it comes to developing your project
and it is also very helpful in case you
are
from an university or an organization
which requires you to record
each step of the internship process
now once you're familiar with the
project
and you have an idea of the kind of
projects you would want to get uh
started with
we recommend the literature review now
we have
uh in our experience seen that there are
two sets of
students or interns who come in uh there
are a few who
already know what kind of project they
would want to work on
and there are others who do not know
what area they are more interested in
and they might have multiple interests
so the literature review
in that case is very helpful to get you
familiar with
the different research techniques and
the different multi-omics and
bioinformatics
research that is going on in that
particular area you may be interested in
so that you can
formulate your own research idea and
then work with your mentor on completing
that project
the fifth step is of course making a
presentation again like this
this exercise is very important and very
soon
we will be seeing our own research
fellows
present some of their projects as well
as their progress
who have been a part of this research
fellowship program
for some time or you know longer
so this presentation is going to be
a final presentation where you would be
presenting your full project
and your progress and then in the sixth
step
peer review so this would not only be
reviewed by our team of mentors
but also it would be reviewed by your
peers and we
definitely recommend you to share it
with your friends and family to make
sure that
if there is someone who does not
understand by informatics
your goal in the project is also clear
to them
now moving on we are going to see some
project presentation
and to start with i would like to invite
our research fellow kalau mari to go
ahead
and share his presentation on
classification of triple negative breast
cancer kalamari over to you
ah thank you i will share my my screen
sure go ahead good morning everyone
can you see my screen yes we can see
your screen collaborating you can go
ahead
okay great i'm going to talk about my
project that is
entitled classification of triple
negative breast cancer cell lines by
gene expression analysis
of strand membrane proteins using
machine learning algorithms
my name is carlo marie major alpena just
to talk a little about
myself i'm from keretaron city in mexico
and i'm a phd
student from the program of
biotechnology
at technological monterey and actually
my phd is about the development of
devices for the diagnosis of triple
negative breast cancer so
i have interest in finding
new biomarkers that could improve the
analysis and the diagnosis of this this
type of disease
just in order to have some context about
the triple negative breast cancer it
represents
from 10 to 20 percent of breast cancer
however it is highly heterogeneous so
it's difficult to
diagnose there are several subtypes
and also
well the main characteristic of this
type of disease
is that these breast cancers they they
have negative
response to estrogen receptors
progesterone receptors and
also epidermal growth factor receptor
as a result the the hormonal and the
immune therapies are not very effective
and also a common is commonly an
an aggressive type of disease so the
treatment is difficult
and early diagnosis is important
in order to have a positive outcome
when you are diagnosed with this disease
so and in order to
to find new biomarkers well
the type of biomarkers i'm interested on
are the
membrane biomarkers because well they
can be used for
for prognostics to know the prognosis
and also
to monitor the development of of
different type of cancer
they also are critical in in they play
an important role
in in cellular structure and function
and also
in the proliferation of cancerous cells
and and also they
they are important as a
drug target in the pharmaceutical
perspective
so for this reason i decided
to generate a question and it says
it is possible to classify breast cancer
cells by gene expression analysis of
strong membrane proteins
using machine learning and well the
hypothesis is that these breast cancers
cell lines can be classified in the
molecular
subtypes using the expression of these
transmembrane proteins and also
implementing
the machine learning algorithms and
the methodology consists in
when one in an approach the first
approach is
it involves the selection of
transmembrane proteins
from the annotation of the genes that
are present in a dataset
then performing some machine learning
analysis
using these genes that are selected
and then validating these
all these genes with with another data
set in order to see
if the machine learning and the genes
are performing
in a proper manner and for the second
approach
in that in this approach the idea is to
select
genes that are useful for the
classification of breast cancer but
that are not necessarily
transmembrane genes and then perform the
the same type of machine learning
analysis and validation
in order to get at the end a list of
transmembrane
genes that are common with both
approaches and
which could be analyzed as candidates
for for diagnosis
and the the two
data sets that i that i used in this
project
and the first one is is based in the
article of modeling precision uh
treatment of breast cancer
and the second one is is a recent data
set
that was used for the external
validation and it was
uh it was from a professor from harvard
medical school
here are the the accession numbers
and for the preparation the the first
step was to homogenize the information
present in the data sets
i employed a quantum normalization with
a threshold of
five then the annotation and the
selection and the analysis and
everything was performed in the
tower bioinformatics research center
the algorithms and all the analysis
and for the first approach uh
160 genes were annotated as
transmembrane and they were
they were selected and a principal
component analysis was performed
and as you can see there are some of the
groups
are easy to identify according to this
analysis
and well it's important to mention that
the luminal vc and basal bc
they are normal breast cancer they are
not triple negative breast cancer
and the other ones are negative triple
negative breast cancer and non-malignant
then uh considering that
106 and 60 genes is a large number
i decided to reduce the number of
of genes and for this i
perform a random forest algorithm and
i use the 10 of the
of the data set to test the algorithm
with an accuracy of 83.3 percent
and here is the the criteria
and mean decrease accuracy bigger or
lower
than two and lower than minus two and
actually i got
four transmembrane genes according to
this filter selection
and as you can see the groups are
are pretty well separated so
this analysis suggests that a
the posterior analysis could provide
interesting results so
i decided to work with the supervised
machine learning analysis
using dimension for the games and
actually the performance
with the first data set wasn't
as as good as expected however well the
number of
samples was reduced so it causes some
difficulties
with the algorithm but during the
validation
using the the second data set
with a larger number of samples to test
well
the the accuracy was was improved and
actually
as you can see is around 90 90 so
i think that this
these genes with the machine learning
algorithm perform well
and then i work in the second approach
and in the second approach i consider
40 14 000 engines
uh from the first data set and and i
also performed
the feature selection using random
forest
and in that case i used an accuracy
larger than 1.2 or smaller than minus
1.2
because yeah the the number were
lower in comparison to the to the other
factor selection and i as a result
i got 133 genes
and as you can see with the principal
component analysis
the groups are pretty well separated
just the the ones of that are breast
cancer
basal breast cancer and luminal breast
cancer are difficult to separate from
the
from the basal and luminal
but in general they look good
so i i perform the supervised machine
learning analysis using dimension gains
and the with the first data set
the the accuracy was was
more was better in that in the
in the previous approach but not as good
as
as i as i expected but during the
uh the external violation with the
second data set
the the accuracy was was good was
over 90 percent so
the all
these machine learning with the genes
work pretty well
and then after all these analysis
i decided to check from the first
approach
using these 40 genes from transmembrane
proteins and and then
try to find which genes are shared by
the two
approaches and according to to this
there were two transmembranes that are
shared by two approaches
so i go these two candidates that
could be useful for for future analysis
so as conclusions uh well the machine
learning algorithms
that were used uh were
good for the classification of breast
cancer cell lines using the
gene expression analysis in both of the
approaches
and actually the support vector machine
algorithm provided
better results in comparing to in
comparison to the random forest
also the machine learning algorithms
were validated with with an external
data set
and but more more external validation
with other dataset is is recommended
in order to to know if the
if the results are consistent
and also the the genes
uh well i obtained two genes that
could be interesting for further
analysis
in in the diagnostic area
and also well it's important to mention
that the
well it did the analysis involved only
the gene expression so other aspects of
cancer are not considered
as the accuracy of the machine learning
algorithm can be improved
by modifying the selection procedure and
modifying the cutoff value
during the vector selection and
also the transmembrane proteins need to
be
confirmed the expression doesn't mean
that the protein is present in the cell
so this conversion is
necessary and well i was expecting
having more than
than two gene but unfortunately just two
two genes archer
with both approaches and that's all
thank you for for your attention
thank you so much uh calamari for this
excellent presentation
um does anyone have any question for
calamari on this project you can
ask us in the chat box or you can
ask i actually have a i actually have a
question
uh calamari could you expand a little
bit more on
uh why you were interested in this
project and what was your previous
experience with bioinformatics and what
have you
learned through this experience
well actually well the
i i had important limitations
with respect to the lab work so i was
trying to find
other ways to complement my my research
that doesn't involve
the use of laboratory facilities and
also well uh bioinformatics i think this
is a very important tool that could
help in in improving the research
without requiring a
a large amount of of
expenditures with respect of reagents
and materials so
i i had this interest
of implementing bioinformatic approaches
in order to
to make a research more efficient
considering the limitations of resources
and facilities
and for this reason i was interested in
joining the
this research internship and actually i
learned a lot
about the use of of these tools and and
the
i think that the data science
perspective is is very useful
because usually the courses about
bioinformatics
they just uh they just tell you how to
use
some of the databases but you don't see
all of that in
in a in a data science perspective so i
think that
this perspective is very useful and
i i got very interesting results that i
i expect to continue working on
one second before we get to those
questions my other question is
so what what are you planning to do with
this project after you're done with this
program
well i would like to to continue with
this project
in order to generate some a paper
so i was thinking that maybe it would be
a good idea to continue
working within the internship or to to
[Music]
to yeah to to enter to the internship
again
in order to continue with some parts of
the project in order to
to generate a publication
okay thank you calamari here i have a
question from dido it's asking have you
tested other ml methods such as gbm or
xboost
i i tested i haven't tested
all the machine learning method i just
tested
linear discriminant analysis and
this was the other method that i tested
and the
in comparison to the random forest and
support vector machine the performance
was lower so i decided to
not continue performing this analysis
but yeah i i just tested these three
methods
linear discriminant analysis support
vector machine and random forest
maybe in the future i will i will test
other other methods
uh thank you for your question dido and
thank you for answering kalamari we have
one more question from janani and then
we'll move on
the question is how did you decide which
aspects of gene expression to analyze
with machine learning
well
in in in my case
well the transmembrane proteins were
relevant
because in the type of devices that i'm
i'm working on it's easy to separate the
cells
using these uh distance membrane
proteins so in my case i was well the
focus was
according to the type of project that
i'm developing so
so i think that this is the
the reason why well that i
decide to to take this perspective
yeah uh thank you so much kalam mari and
i would now like to invite sonalika
to go ahead and share her review of the
liver cancer project
so and thank you kalamari
thank you
greeting everybody is my screen visible
yes sonalika we can see your screen
okay so um
um so nalika we cannot hear you clearly
your connection must be disrupting
uh hi biksha so maybe we can move on to
the next presentation meanwhile so
nadika
can so i'm sorry that sonalika is having
some trouble
uh regarding her network issue so i
would like to
invite avio bruno to share
his project on identification
characterization and expression analysis
of cell wall
related genes as primary targets for
efficient biofilm production in sorghum
bicolor
so avio please go ahead
and now we also please make sure to
unmute yourself
hello hello avio yes we can hear you and
also see your screen
please go ahead okay okay thank you
i'm called bruno uh my presentation is
on identification
calculation an expression analysis of
cellular related genes as primary
targets for efficient biofuel production
in southern bicola
i'll not give a background to the study
uh
my as i had prepared this presentation
with focus of
only providing uh providing feedback on
the progress that i've made
i'm having four objectives i'm going to
present
mainly the progress on one objective
on the fourth objective which i'm
looking at calculation of transcriptome
pattern of sodium
cellular related genes under moisture
stress and under
differing developmental cross stages
under differing developmental growth
stages i'm having three
three different data sets uh
uh three different data sets from
[Music]
uh uh looking at transcription data at
vegetative and reproductive stage of
sorghum
so from the first data set it was from a
study by makita ital 2015
uh where transcription data was taken
at a reproductive reproductive stage
mainly taking transcription data from
speculator and stem
and from seed at average maturity
and here they collected they had
transcription data on
10 10 different samples for the second
data set transcript transcription data
was taken from a 20 day old leaf
and they they they had 10 srnf
sri sria files
uh the third data set looked into a
transcription data from
a vegetative and reproductive stage
on a sub subset of the study two
of style of the same study uh
the interest was so to look at gene
expression analysis under
various biotic stresses with focus on
drought
and this uh the data was obtained from
uh
from dugas the tile 2011 where
sra sra sequence data was collected
at uh at seedling stage
from shoot and roots under
other four different treatments i'll
give her
the presentation will mainly uh provide
analysis
for subsection 2 which is 4.2
uh with this study what was done was
that the uh
seeds of a single genotype
[Music]
instead of one genotype that is a bt
btx 623 was planted
what was planted and and was planted
and once after the third day once they
have already
once the seeds have already germinated
the seeds the seedlings were transferred
into
uh a controlled chamber room and kept
him there till the eighth day
and on the eighth day the the
uh the uh the seedlings were put into
uh the seedlings were put into four
different groups
and in group one uh the seedlings were
spread with abscisic acid
abscisic acid and group 2 was spread
with
sodium hydroxide group 3 was
spread by polyethylene glycol and
and the last the the last group was
sprayed with
with water basically sodium
sodium hydroxide acted as a control for
abscess
acid and water acted as a control for
poly uh polyethylene glycol
so uh after the treatment uh
uh i uh arrange a transcript
where uh where where
uh where where were obtained from root
and shoot
from from bluetooth shoot um
from root and shoot with
each group having three replicates
as you can see from uh from my diagram
so i i performed an analysis
uh basically the analysis that i've
conducted up to now
is more of an exploratory
and exploratory uh kind of analysis
so i i did a gene expression analysis
where
uh the transcript were mapped onto the
uh
where were mapped using multi voltaic
tutti
and i from the trans
from the expression analysis that was
that i did i obtained
over 24 24 000 genes
and these were designated as us lux
subic and then uh trna
as uh as of uh summarize also
summarize that summarize uh summarize on
it
on the slide so
at the beginning i first i first
did a test i
first performed a test a test a test
analysis where
a subset a subset of
a subset of of six
sra files were analyzed
and this uh these six sra files
were from well from two two different
treatments that
is sodium hydroxide and pig
sodium hydroxide and peg and i observed
that uh
uh from the principal content analysis
that i conducted
they were nicely separated into two
groups based on the
uh business based on the treatment
condition
and similarly i did a
cluster trust analysis and
the same observation was observed
the same observation was observed i i
tried to assess the relationship between
samples from the same treatment uh so
this is from uh this is from uh
sodium hydroxide and peg and i observe
that there is a
uh there is a strong relationship
between the
between the gene expression part and
other day
between the gene expression pattern of
of
of of samples of samples that were
treated
that were treated that had the same that
had the same treatment
which shows that the data is the quality
of the data is quite good
so i i went ahead and looked into
and i looked into the the distribution
the distribution of the of the data set
on box plot and observed that there are
some
some some outliers or
some outliers in all the in all the in
all the samples
but uh what i observe is that the
the median of the median of all data
were
where we are quite related and the
and the uh and the extent of the
variation uh
extent of the variation in the uh
under the under the treatment under the
different treatment conditions were
quite
related so i went ahead and now
looked into the all all the 24 sra files
and performed a similar kind of analysis
that i did with
six ssri files and observed that
i observed uh using the principal
component analysis i observed
i observed uh
i observed four different sets of
clusters
of four different sets of clusters and
when i performed
a dendrogram when i performed
when i went ahead and did this on on
dentogram
i observed a similar trend the similar
observation that i
that that the principal component
revealed was also revealed here and
we had two uh it showed two major
clusters
two major clusters basically uh this
split the data based on the uh based on
the
plant uh based on the plant organ so
this uh this major cluster basically are
shoots
and this uh these these clusters
are basically roots and in between here
i've got
four clusters which are which are
separated based on the treatment
the kind of treatment so from this i
observe that i can really get very
interesting
uh genes differentially expressed genes
first of all between between the organs
and and among us the treatment
among us the the mangas they treat among
us the four
among us the four types of treatment so
i'm hoping that
with this data i can get very
interesting uh
very interesting genes that relates to
cell wall
that relates that relates to cell wall
data related to cellular plant cell
so i did i went ahead and looked at
looked at the the nature of variation
the nature of variation on the box plot
i still
observed uh the the extent of the
the extent of the the variation uh
under the different under the different
plant organ and treatment level
were almost the same were
almost the same but from this
from the root i observed relatively
that there could be some outliers that i
that
that needs to be looked into and
probably trim off
but the shoots looks relatively okay
i i my focus i
i i went ahead and tried to look into
uh finding out
which genes are expressed differently
under the
under under the different treatment
under the different treatment
different types of treatment and
different organs
i this is the pipeline i followed
unfortunately i did i performed this
analysis
and the output that i obtained
uh the the folders were empty and i
failed to understand where the
challenge was so i from the analysis
that i've conducted this
is this is where this is where i ended
but uh
the the expression the the genes that
i uh that are indicated in my
gene expression table the in terms of
location locks
locks and other and other types of them
so
once once i obtain the genes that are
differentially expressed
the genes that are differentially
expressed i can search for the
the gene names from from the sorghum
gene database
and once i obtain those genes i believe
i should be able to go
and perform my gene ontology analysis
and try to
identify those genes that are strongly
related with
cell wall that are strongly related that
data related to cell wall
that participate in in cell wall cell
wall
regulation and
uh and another challenge that i faced
was that uh
in the uh um uh
for for the subsection one where i'm
looking at
where i'm looking at gene expression
under different growth stages i'm having
three different sets of files
i i have no idea how
these three different sets of files can
be
can be combined as one in order to
in order to have as in order to conduct
perform analysis as one
as one set of experiment
so that's why my challenges that i face
during the day
yeah thank you uh thank you it's really
exciting to see the progress with your
project that you're getting some insight
so
thank you for sharing that about the
technical part of your question how to
combine multiple
uh data sets together all you need to do
really is just to create
one single table with all of those links
and then use
ncbi upload tool so that you will get
all of them
combined together what you probably need
to consider afterwards however is
how to normalize the data so that it
actually is consistent maybe removing
some batch effects
and so these are things that we can
address in our next meeting one-on-one
to kind of
discuss some of these challenges but i
think overall
you're off to a great start it would be
really exciting to see
what else you find in your data
but so far i think it looks really good
thank you
thank you so much have you and thank you
so now i would like to invite sonalika
back
i think her issues are solved so so
nalika you can go ahead
and share your project again
good evening everybody i'm really sorry
for the glitch
i'm sanalika ray currently pursuing
masters in bioinformatics from punjab
university chandigarh
uh today i'm here to discuss the major
findings of hepatocellular carcinoma
which is abbreviated as fcc and i would
be shedding light on the risk factors
involved gene mutations treatments and
what are the different scopes of
research in this field
so what does hcc it is the most common
form of liver cancer
it is a second leading cause of cancer
death in the in the world
and there are between 6 lakh to 1
million new hcc cases in the world
annually so this is clearly still an
important area of basic science clinical
science and drug development
the highest incidence and mortality of
hcc are
observed in east asia africa europe and
in the us
a now i would like to discuss few of the
risk
factors which are associated with scc so
patients will
consumption are have the major is b
virus or hepatitis c virus uh
then nafld
hi sonalika we have lost you again
nash that is non-alcoholic sets the
polymorphisms in the in these three
genes which i've mentioned
hi sonalika uh we are keeping on like
losing you
um i mean it's not very clear to a
fashion sec incident
another risk factors are statuses from
by
hi sonalika can you hear me can you
please
yes yeah yeah so we keep on continue to
lose you so your connection is like
fluctuating
maybe you can go a little slow because
we kind of mixed
out on a lot of the things while you are
explaining the risk factors thank you
hi sonalika i think that uh because of
your issue
we would be looking at your project in
the next time
i mean we cannot hear you at all so i
would like to pass it on to the next
person so in our next meeting
uh you can go ahead and again address
everybody so thank you so much sonalika
i'm sorry that your connection is not
working out
and i would like now like to invite
fazan amit
to go ahead and give us a review of his
progress so far so fazan is joining
us uh just since the last week
so what we are going to do is see how he
has progressed and he is also going to
introduce himself to us
so farzan please go ahead
and also please unmute yourself
so can you hear me yeah we can hear you
and i hope you can see my screen as well
right yeah
we can see your screen as well okay so
my name is fazan ahmed
um i am a final year student
in beta bioinformatics at amity
university noida
so i just joined this program about
10 days ago so at this point i'm really
just going through
the courses i'm trying to get a grasp of
what i can do and what is available
okay so i started off with the
introduction to
bioinformatics course um where
i learned the basic concepts
involved in bioinformatics such as
whole transcript what is available over
here
[Music]
and what we base
what we are basically doing in
bioinformatics and
why it's important
so there are many different areas of
study within this field as well such as
and one of the
fields in which i'm interested in in
personalized medicine
and hopefully once i'm done with the
courses
i can pursue a project related to
personalized medicine
and over here we basically consider
genomic and metabolic data
to provide the to provide a suitable
treatment to a group of patients and in
personalized medicine we
also look at
[Music]
diagnosing a disease or a condition
at an earlier stage so we can treat it
on time
on this especially useful in cancer
and this is enabled by the vast
amounts of amount of data which is the
genomic data that is
available
the other areas where we can also apply
it is in
environmental science um we can apply it
in microbial communities which is
known as metagenomics
so this is basically the summary of
what i went through in introduction to
bioinformatics
the second course that i'm also pursuing
now is epigenetics um this is a course
that i've actually never studied um
so this is the first time i'm actually
going through what epigenetics really
is i've heard of the term but i never
really
uh studied it in depth so it's exciting
for me to
see this um i just started this course a
few days back actually
and so far i just learned that it's a
field that studies interactions between
genes
and products that bring phenotypes into
existence
and this is the field that has been
linked to
um this epigenetics is actually linked
to mechanisms
that affect the
stability and the folding of the dna um
i've also i'm also at the same time
exploring the dbio info platform
that i that i recently gained access to
apart from that i've also i'm also
planning on starting the transcriptomics
course
and maybe along the way make some
progress
and hopefully uh plan a project
that that is
useful so that's
it for now actually thank you so much
fazan
thank you for giving us this review and
it's good to see your progress in the
last 10 days
so now i would want to invite swati to
talk about her progress so swati has
been already a part of one of our omits
logic
programs and she has some experience
utilizing the tools
so she has also joined the research for
the ship program
to work on her own independent project
so we will be hearing from swati so
swadhi please go ahead
yeah uh i hope i'm audible and my screen
is visible
sure swati yes we can see you and also
hear
you see your screen please go ahead
so to introduce myself um i'm swati
a third year undergraduate i'm studying
at a mit att university
pursuing bioengineering i'm very very
interested in pursuing bioinformatics
for
my highest studies as well i don't have
any research experience in
bioinformatics
but i have taken a summer training
at pine bio and i wish to pursue a
project
too with this internship opportunity
so i'll just be sharing um what i have
covered so far
in the course
all right um
so i covered the um
r and python bioinformatics course
modules
so it started off with how
we import various tables excel files
and csv files into both r
and python i learned to split data
as a data frame and also in the form of
a matrix
uh so the next part of this module was
pre
processing of the data which basically
means that most of the times in the data
there
are any values basically empty values or
zero values
which interfere with the analysis
methods
so it's important to get rid of this
before running your pipeline
um so some of the theory that was
covered
in these modules were basic theory on
dna structure
and function and of course the first
step in the central dogma
which is replication uh the course also
talked about
how uh chymas so cdks
um play an important role in controlling
initiation
of the replication process and how
various uh proteins are involved in the
elongation and domination of this
very extensive process as well
the highlight for me of both these
courses
were learning about bioconductor
which basically offers various libraries
like biostring
and a cipher which was completely new to
me
so as far as i have learned they are
used for memory efficient string
containers
string matching algorithms and other
utilities for
manipulation of large biological
sequences or sets of sequences
as a part of an assignment and exercise
in the course
i use these libraries to find
length of a given dna sequence the
frequency of the bases in the sequence
and also the reverse complement of
the secret yeah
that's my progress so far thank you
thank you so much swati so now i would
like to
thank all of our research fellows who
took the time
to talk about their progress and share
with us
what they have done so far and also talk
about their
projects so what we do from time to time
the research fellowship program is not
just
a program where you come and do your own
research project or get training
what we want to do is enable you
to not only prepare that research
project but take it
further so we want to enable you we want
to make sure that
your research project is uh getting the
word of the mouth so we utilize our
social media channels here you can see
simai is one of our research fellows she
recently
completed her fellowship program and her
project
and we have featured her in this blog
post
that gives her access to a wider
audience who can learn about her project
similarly we also have de lara who has
joined along with simai they both
are from the bachelor university in
turkey
and we keep on featuring students like
them who perform
and do well in a program like this so
the research fellowship program
not only comes with a project that you
design on your own
but there is also a certification that
you receive
at the end of this course which states
how you have performed during this
entire period of three months six months
or any other period that you are
choosing to do the research fellowship
so i welcome you to go ahead and check
out
and also there are other posts on our
blog
which i had mentioned earlier where you
can see why
other participants are recommending
these programs
and i want to again continue to invite
you to go ahead
and join our channel and now i have
a last poll for all of you
that i would be launching in a minute
so if you are intending to join the
research fellowship or you have just
joined right now you can see the poll
which asks you a question what is your
expectation from this research
fellowship training
then the second question is how many
hours per week can you dedicate to this
training this is very important when you
are starting to work
on your own research project and
what are your future goals whether you
want to work
in the industry which is a
bioinformatics industry for a company
or you're looking forward to work in
academia or if you have any other goals
so please put in your bold result that
way
and the fourth question is what did you
think of today's session so
please go ahead and share your results
and i will quickly
check the chat box
so there are a few questions on how can
i join the research fellowship program
so the first step to join the research
fellowship program
is to sign up for the program so as the
poll is going on i will go ahead
and make sure that i can
show you how to join this program so i
hope that
you all can see my stream so this is the
link
to join the program so
there are also scholarship opportunities
for students who are in need of
scholarships
so we do have a few scholarship
opportunities
and i would be sending you the links to
those scholarship opportunities
after this session and you can also
reach out to me in marketing at find out
bio
in case you have any specific question
regarding joining
this program so the research fellowship
program
is open not only for individual students
in fact
you can also join with your peers and
work on a group project
right now the project that i showed you
on alzheimer's are by
a student who are working on in a group
along with a researcher and
they are together collaborating on that
alzheimer's project so let us go back
to the blog and take a look at it so
maybe
we can go through it together and i will
be able to show you
how that is going on so all of these
projects
or any of these projects you can either
do on your own
along with the mentor support that we
would be providing
and going forward you can also
collaborate with others so there is a
question if
some research project is going to be
published
who will be the author so in this
research projects
you are the one you are the author of
these projects
because what we are helping you do is
come up with your own project
so you are going to be the authors while
the rest of the things that could be our
team
like your mentor could be a co-author in
that project
but publication is something which is a
very long drawn out cost
process so in three months or six months
it is not always possible to come up
with a full fledged publication
so what we try to do first
uh is to make sure that you can come up
with a project like you saw that
kalamari has presented
or avio has presented a project which
you can then work towards a publication
and often the challenge
is to find the right data sets or to
find
the right steps of analysis and that
is where most of your time will go in in
figuring out
in the next three months or six months
like how to
make sure that you're getting everything
right for the project so i've put the
link to this
omits project omix blog post
in the chat box
and i will also be answering a few of
the questions so there is a question
from
faria she's asking can a student of
undergrad
biotech apply for this fellowship or
should we wait for the completion of her
bsc so right now
just taking an example of the
alzheimer's project
this project is being done by two
students who are
in a high school level so they both are
high school students
andres and netra and they are doing this
project so
this project will give you an
understanding
of the kind of data sets that they are
using the approach that they have taken
to do this project and this actually is
open source so any of you can create an
account
on edu device for portal and read about
this project
so you would see what kind of
publications they have been using
and what they are trying to achieve with
this project so
anyone starting from a high school to
any kind of post graduation post
post-doc level
can come and join the research
fellowship program we have
participants who join us from all over
the world who come from different
educational backgrounds so everyone is
welcome to join
and as i showed you while i was
presenting earlier we follow that
step-by-step process where we start with
the very basic courses
and go in a step-by-step process where
you learn
about the logic learn about the data
learn where you can get that kind of
data
identify projects which are similar to
yours do literature review
find the kind of project topic that you
would want to work in
along with your mentor so this is a
program that comes with a full mentor
support so you work
with someone from our team
who would be able to work on this
project
so hello
uh regarding your application if you're
already a part of
another program and you still want to
apply for this scholarship so we will be
having
like a one-on-one meeting with you again
and
decide whether that is something that we
can offer for you
so please take your time to go through
all of these free resources that are
available to you
please go through the introduction to
buy informatics course
and if you are applying for
the research fellowship program what we
would
want to learn more about you is like
what is your area of interest so
doing the introduction to buying for
matrix course
is going to be very helpful because the
intro survey will tell us a lot about
what you want to do so this program is
not about
the projects that we are offering but it
is about what you are interested in
pursuing not only right now but also
in the future so please feel free to
join us and if there are
no more questions so i would like to
thank everyone for
attending today's session and welcome
you all
again to join our programs and follow us
on our social media
so thank you everybody for joining us
today
and have a great week
you